regardez autour de vous regardez en bas du pâté de maisons de
vous le visage solitaire est que vous voyez
la bombe d'Esmeralda fait de l'argent comme un rêve
deux mille livres par semaine un pur profit
il n'y avait rien à faire mais en profiter
posséder ce casino signifiait tout pour
Reggie qu'il finirait par traverser  la frontière
entre le vieil East End et les verts
pâturages du Golden West, il
devenait lui-même une célébrité tant que
leur santé n'en souffrait pas les gros
joueurs adoraient côtoyer des
gangsters ou des aristocrates et les criminels
ont beaucoup en commun ils sont  les deux
égoïstes s'ennuient facilement et ont accès
à des liasses d'argent, ils n'ont pas eu à travailler
honnêtement pour obtenir le top ni
aucun intérêt pour les règles bourgeoises sur la
moralité, le tout mis ensemble avec des
roues de roulette
une recette étonnante pour le succès ron était
l'homme étrange  sa pilule l'a stabilisé
mais ils ne le tueraient jamais. Le club atterrit avec un
tambour à lèvres et il aspire à Reggie
et au côté obscur du service des
gangs.